good breaking news everybody shots this
is from the police tribune is this
is this verif this is a verified source
blue lives matter dot blue
this is a verified news guard source
okay it's not giving me the actual
breakdown two
two officers down two two cops down in
louisville
shots fired at louisville riots officer
down they're saying update two officers
are now reported to be down
the shooting happened at around 8 30 p.m
near brook and broadway according to
wdrb
officers in the area were working on
crowd control at a riot when the
gunshots rang
out and two officers were hit the
condition of the wounded officers has
not been released no information about
the shooter has been released
so we've got a tweet here from fallon
glick verified twitter user and
twitter's giving us the business
i want to make sure i want to see what
her credentials are she says she
confirms
an officer was just shot she's with wdrb
news
and uh it so i don't know where the
update is on the second officer but it
looks like
let me read what they say they say
authorities began planning for violent
rights in the city this we know the lmpd
declared a state of emergency we get it
so i think this is these are the updates
we're looking at right now so let's
let's let's do this man i i hate to
shift from the conversation because it
was getting funny we'll go back to
louisiana okay
but this is this this is some serious
stuff man yeah uh
look we got we got we got you here maj
you're the you're the guy from black
guns matter
what what tell us like what are your
what are your thoughts on that because
everybody knows what i think when we
talk about this stuff the universe is
self-correcting on the state
you and first of all but condolences to
those offices
yeah man i don't know if they had
anything to do with any of that
plot random plot twists might be that
they were actually the guys that's like
look
i'm trying to help you know what i mean
and that could be the case i don't know
him
but until i know him to be good or bad
my initial reaction is yo
hope those guys pull through yeah man um
do you watch all game of thrones before
before i got garbage no no so listen
literally literally i started watching
game of thrones
about four or five months ago all right
i had never saw it
and i was like this is wizards dragons
there's no wizards i don't think
right but that's how i was they're kind
of lizard yeah and so
um that's an amazing sidebar i wouldn't
have killed khaleesi
if i was john all right so anyway here's
why i bring this up yeah because there
there there was a
one of the story arcs in one of the
camera which season was is khaleesi
takes over a slaver town
yes and then executes all of the
privileged class like the elite class
yeah and then this young man comes and
says my father was the one
fighting to free them the one who was
providing them with comfort you killed
him
and he was a good guy and that to me is
like
it look man that's the crux you know
what i don't you know what i can't stand
for
the system being broken being being
broken
and then like look there are certain
things
this is such a hard ethical conundrum
man there are certain things where we
just see it and it must be stopped
right genocides right we're talking
right now about a system with a with a
high margin of error in certain areas
that needs to be corrected
correct to go up to some like these
these cops i'll tell you what men
these cops are probably sitting at home
they're probably playing ps4 they're
probably playing some you know they're
probably playing skyrim or some simple
game
right dude's probably 28 30. he's got a
kid he's got a wife
and they say hey man there's going to be
you know protests tonight and he's like
oh i guess i got they're needing me to
come in right the wife his wife's like
be careful you know it's getting crazy
with watching the news
he doesn't know anything about these
people he doesn't know anything about
trump he doesn't know anything about
biden
i mean at this point people are probably
very political but you're probably
getting these guys who are just like
i don't know man just i gotta go to work
i'm going to work they told me there's
we got to keep people safe right you
know i want to make sure that these
protests are safe and none of this
happens and then boom shot to the head
so there's regular like looking systems
busted but come on man
these people got families they're people
i agree with that and as a human
i'm like empathy you know our three-step
method is
empathy facts solution i got to deal
with empathy first before i can start
talking about the data
right then we can come up with a
solution together so empathy first
the fact of the matter is just like
brianna taylor
was killed right and it's the state's
fault in the systemic
those officers that blood is on that
same if that
who's the person that
wrote the warrant the guy that they were
looking for was already
in custody so when are we talking about
that person being held accountable it's
just the problem is
all of the death from that and you got a
sore rose crew that's gonna jump in and
hyper extend it and turn it up and media
and
ratings and all this other stuff i wanna
i wanna i wanna switch it up on you
though i wanna say mackenzie bezos
okay she's she's directly funded i think
two billion dollars straight into
intersectional far left organizations
and stuff as well i'm just i'm
mentioning that because
whenever the source name pops up i'm
like oh let's name all the billionaires
right
right all the millionaires billionaires
funding this stuff funding this stuff
it it turns into um now this is the part
where again
my hood friends would go like come on
bro it's like there's people that have
generated resources from
america that still
feel
like they have to def knock down america
where they actually live well because
i'm a billionaire and i may actually be
a citizen of like
monaco you know i think you know i think
it is i think a lot of these rich people
are funding the far left in hopes that
if there ever is a revolution
they're the good ones right i could see
that
it's not gonna it's not gonna work it's
not gonna work because of the fact that
there were people remember in the movie
the dark knight with bain
yeah and everybody that thought they was
cool and safe and it's like no
once we got rid of that we still coming
to holiday too it works
you know what i'm saying and so it's
that same concept i think i think warren
buffett said this
i could be wrong so you know please
don't sue me warren buffett but just
just
fact check this something about that you
know he he did this thing where he like
called on billionaires to donate a big
portion of their wealth mm-hmm and he
was bait he
he alluded to the fact that with like
all the occupy stuff and the challenge
of the one percent
the rich were too rich and if they sat
back and kept doing the same thing they
always did
eventually pitchforks are going to show
up napoleon said
religion is here so the poor
don't murder the rich did he really say
that
napoleon bonaparte so are these the
pitchforks so yeah and so some of that
is
some of that is listen and this is where
i might get a little
right america has not atoned
our nation where we all live
has not atoned for some of the horrible
disgusting stains that we have on our
flag
karma in my view in my life and lived
experience is real
we haven't acknowledged you haven't even
had the conversation about reparations
with black people
you haven't had it and then you'll say
well who's gonna pay for i'm not gonna
pay for it
we can't do that then you print up three
trillion dollars
and the government gets really
quiet and everybody seems to know how to
get along then
except for my good friend thomas massey
the one lone
constitutional libertarian dude that had
to run republican
says no i'm not gonna quietly not vote
on this
largest wealth transfer in american
history socialism
so you haven't a tone for the
vilest type of because oh
slavery has existed in in time
immemorial but the mafa the
millions of melanated beings that were
murdered
that created the economic infrastructure
of america the place that we live
right that i love because i'm not one of
those like
slavery happened burned down america bro
i like wi-fi
i like i like dunkin donuts i love where
i live
you know what i'm saying cheeseburger's
on demand you simpson yeah with this
being the case
karmically if you have not atoned for
that
and your systemic issues that need
correction
are now being exploited by very
resourceful
people that don't have an actual stake
in the country anymore
and now you instead of dealing with that
you want to pretend like oh everything's
cool it's great here
you're not addressing those issues and
those you got like
we ain't got to go all the way back we
could talk about redlining we could talk
about this we could talk testing
right i was when you brought up
reparations i was ready to jump in
because i i don't agree
but then you mentioned the printing
three trillion six trillion and i'm like
i got no justification dude they're
gonna print money and just throw it
around
and and if it's no issue right if if
if austrian economics and and mises
and these guys these really smart guys
are wrong
then okay then why don't we just we can
solve all of this
let's just print up 300 million dollars
since it's no issue with inflation and
hyperinflation
it doesn't affect our economy and we can
say
okay we're going to give every american
as reparations we're going to give
one we're going to give every american
one million dollars and that would be
like three trillion something yeah 300
or like 300
no how many people is in america 300
million yeah
so that's like 300 trillion we only need
1 million per person
so one million three hundred million
dollars no no it's one million times 300
million oh yeah
so it's like 300 trillion whatever that
is that number but that's that's just
but it doesn't matter because we just
printed up three it would
what would happen is three quadrillion
so so look is it
well so whatever that math turns out to
if you're saying that there's no issue
with printing up endless three trillion
dollars i know man
let's just give let's give african
americans even if they gave them like
1.25 or whatever the number well so but
but here
so if you were talking only about black
americans which is i believe about 13
of the population it's a lot less than
300 trillion
but there's still a lot though it's it's
a solvent 300 trillion bucks everyone
gets
i'm cool with saying everybody gets the
million right
because it's going to go back into the
economy everyone gets the millions
rapidly and and
african americans can get 1.5 fair
or everybody gets half a million and
then because if it's no issue with the
printing of the money
i see you're saying no it'll make
hamburgers go to like 75
no way way more than that and the same
thing will happen would you throw
three trillion dollars into the exactly
i've seen it go up 30 20
stuff's up inflatable saying this to say
america
and my jewish brothers and sisters have
gotten reparations
the japanese americans and their lineage
that were held in internment camps
after the war were given their
reparations what do you think about
basic
income i think that everyone should be
able to determine what they want to
charge for their labor
but just like the fact if everyone could
get like a thousand dollars a month from
the government
i don't the government that it's not the
government's money it's already your
money it's your
money but if it was disbursed evenly
that's socialism right but so would be
300 trillion dollar bailout right the
same thing that's why thomas massey was
like
bro so so just to make sure i have it
clear
you're basically dragging the government
for just printing money like crazy
i'm dragging the government for being a
tr i'm dragging the american people that
go into politics
that don't understand that they're a
public servant and this
cornucopia of money that you think is
what it is
since you're throwing the money at that
problem but you haven't thrown money at
the community
that has been affected and impacted most
negatively by and anyone that disagrees
with this you either don't read enough
or you're just in denial the thing about
slavery we kind of talked about this a
little bit ago is that
what 150 years ago people were just
dumped on the street with no education
or money at all
and a lot of people are coming from like
their great great grandfather
had nothing did bear maybe didn't even
speak the language very well
that's not the case for a lot of white
well like whatever you want to call it
but we're not white but here's the thing
but here's the thing
you got indigenous people to this nation
that were mixed in some
at one point they were called negro or
indian then you got the people that you
brought from somewhere else
you got you got companies before he was
before he died johnny cochran was
putting together a a thing a fund
on reparations before he you know died
you have companies that benefited
tremendously financially from that
you to bring it back home you haven't
atoned for these things
let's let's we we haven't and if we
haven't and if the system is still in
alignment with those things
i can understand why somebody would be
so damn frustrated and then media
highlights it
and it makes it and and is it as insane
as media is making it absolutely not
however this is what you get and you
have people that have
that lived experience with law
enforcement which is the physical
representation
of a system that's what law enforcement
officers are
they are foot soldiers for policy they
are there to enforce laws and if the
laws are unjust
what what does this community have to
lose in that regard
let me ask you uh you're familiar with
the phrase if you teach a man uh if you
give a man a fish feed him for a day
teach him man to fish
eat him for the rest of his life yeah do
you agree with that yes how would you
feel about
creating a system where you just give
people the fish
that's it you you take the fish from one
guy and give it to the other people so
they have fish that's socialism i'm
not an alignment so here's here's what
i'm getting at i've had a lot of
conversations about reparations
and i think you can't just give money to
people so why did the government print
three
dude i'm with you man they're just
dumping like that's what they're doing
this is an example i agree i agree well
we can't give it to you
guys who clearly have been impacted by
these policies that we as the government
set up but we can section off 24. i got
the 900 page
thing you can section off 24 million for
us and senate
out of the air thin printed money fiat
we got to get our we got to get our
salary increases boom but here's what
i'm saying in terms of reparation
the way i describe it is so i consider
myself liberal meaning
i actually think social programs can be
a good thing i think
the government you know we all we all
pitch in uh uh
taxes do a subscription program and then
there can be social programs to benefit
people in certain circumstances
but i think we're doing it wrong the way
i see it is we shouldn't be giving
people fish that's what we're doing
yeah we're giving people no we should be
teaching people to fish correct so what
we say is you're down and out
you got no fishing pole you don't have a
fish all right we're gonna pitch and get
you paul teach you to fish now now go do
your thing these were things that were
taught up until the 60s
and 50s like the black community wasn't
as like
like there was a systematic attack
on the black community the blm folks
just took it off of their website like
yesterday
another re-attack on the nuclear family
it was nixon
yeah right it was that's a bad thing
it's a bad thing but if you're biased at
that point
nixon was tricky dick you know what i
mean and there was he had interest
in other areas of corporate scenarios
like this
obamacare that was initially created
under nixon
we couldn't really get it off the same
way then you know what i'm saying so
with that being the case
we had these things we had trades
america in general
when people go well when was america
great when one we had
very little international interference
right
when america when pittsburgh was making
30 percent of the world's
steel when you know that's fast
factories 30 percent of the world steel
pittsburgh
steelers when wow women
know that when
black businesses and i'm not saying this
to you know
ignore white families i'm just talking
about the black community because that's
where i happen to live
right when black communities guys could
work a job
plumber trades were taught in school i
live up the street from mural dobbins in
philly
right off the 22nd and lehigh that
school was a trade school
carpentry electrician home economics
hair
all these different things right someone
could have a
legitimate sixty seven seventy thousand
dollar a year job
even back then fifty thousand dollars a
year and not even have to leave the
neighborhood
detroit manufacturing when corporate
interests decide to put
their profits as over making america
solid and making us
economic world power the first you know
center of the scope is the black
community
the people that are doing that manual
labor you know
that are that can make a good wage i can
walk home for lunch
i can walk to work i can walk back home
i can be with my family
there was a systematic attempt to
destroy that it's happening now again
it's just now my white brothers and
sisters y'all caught up it's called
robotics
is like is that what black lives matter
is doing destroying the family
absolutely that's part of their goal
because they know i know it's in their
goal for yeah
they got rid of it they're they're not
they're not black people
they're the the leadership not the face
like aunt jemima and uncle ben
they're like come on they have no jemima
wasn't even black
no i'm sorry i'm sorry mrs butterworth
is gonna say no he's wrong
at the damn executive board meetings you
know what i'm saying the founder of bet
is not the owner of bet anymore yeah so
my point in saying that is
this this is a holistic approach
and now what we're seeing in some of
these you're seeing the frustration of
people
that a have been made to feel like
they're outside of the american dream
there have been policies and systemic
issues
that have deliberately made that the
case now do you have to submit to it
absolutely not
i don't i don't care what they meant the
second amendment for this is mine
yeah you know what i'm saying like oh
you didn't mean that for me that's great
good for you not for me you put a riot
in my neighborhood and you watch me flip
real fast on 2a because i used to be
very
much more like liberal right and you're
like on the right i'm seeing the
helicopters and i'm like i'm like
my gun right now i'm like get away from
my guns exactly
and so these are the things because you
your your course of re-education or your
re-engineering of self
is different and is tied into the human
right at to defend
as opposed to what the government said i
got it now when you're tying it back to
all of these
it's not all of these it's a few people
defending the riots that are not from
the communities
it's it's it's a it's a um a well-oiled
machine
pretending and piggybacking on the back
of
legitimate legitimate social issues
i'm not talking about like oh like
you know i'm getting treated horribly
because they didn't like
like me i'm talking about like school
choice is real you know what i'm saying
like when you're talking about
um discrimination based on skin tone and
bias those are real things that we
can show evidence and fact improve so
when you're not from that demographic
and you don't feel that
and you don't do anything our nation for
the most part
has not atoned in these communities and
atonement doesn't just mean an apology
an atonement means changed behavior
and the behavior hasn't changed i feel
like
one of the problems we have what i was
alluding to earlier is
just throwing throwing fish at people
yeah like okay there you go we gave you
fish now
but you know ian mentioned it earlier
because i've actually done
a lot of research into this i've done a
documentary on stuff like this
you end slavery yeah you don't wh what
you have now is
you know two separate train tracks so i
kind of describe it one which has a
history and one which just started
yeah and doesn't have the same resources
same access so like ian brought up
a grandfather you know a guy is is a
slave he gets freed
he has kids they have nothing to
transfer down to each other right and
they also
don't have the education right and so
that's why i i lean liberal on a lot of
issues like
can we teach people to fish and then
make sure we we fix the system
now yes and agreed but here's the other
part to that example you just gave
then a group of people decide to say you
know what guys we were doing the same
thing we can just do what we all
were doing on that plantation for our
own neighborhood
and then over time that neighborhood
starts to become independent
and it starts to actually that other
side of the tracks literally
is tulsa literally black wall street
literally that other side of the track
starts to look better than this side
then it gets burned down then they re-do
it
then they re build it and it's there for
40 more years
then they re they zone it and they do
things to systematically destroy it
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you